c'est tout nouveau pour nous mettre
désormais ces produits sont fabriqués en
france
à trappes il ya encore six mois nous les
importerons de grand bretagne
désormais nous nous préparons les
réexporter sur le marché britannique
c'est l'une des activités de cette
entreprise impactés par le break site la
fabrication de ces rampes d'accès pour
les personnes à mobilité réduite
implantée à trappes aksoy a conçu cet
atelier de production en juillet 2020
après le rachat d'une société
britannique
l'atelier était en angleterre étaient
près de manchester effectivement une
société qui existait depuis 35 ans et
donc été amenée malheureusement a déposé
le bilan fin mars à fin mars 2009 et
nous étions leurs plus gros clients
or hors uk le dirigeant d'apple a
préféré internaliser cette production
pour avoir le contrôle
avec ensuite la volonté d'exporter au
royaume uni la difficulté pour lui en
janvier 2021 à quel prix peut-il vendre
ses produits
aujourd'hui vendre un particulier en
grande-bretagne pour moins de 135 livres
sterling c'est le particulier qui va
payer la tva plus de 135 livres sterling
c'est le l'exportateur qui payent la tva
plus les frais de transport qui vont
légèrement augmenter
autre impact pour cette entreprise sur
cette chaise d'évacuation pour personnes
en situation de handicap
axsun importe plusieurs de ses produits
auprès d'un fournisseur britannique des
biens à distribuer ensuite en france la
sortie du royaume uni de l'union
européenne va avoir quelques
conséquences
maintenant tout est organisé au niveau
des transporteurs en tout cas en ce qui
concerne leurs systèmes ont été modifiés
donc les procédures de déclaration de
marchandises vont être faites comment on
fait déjà pour la suisse où les autres
pays hors union
donc en fait le brésil devrait impliquer
donc plus de papier plus d'administratif
mais également des délais de livraison
plus long cette société emploie 14
personnes attrapées réalise 2 millions
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires